hey I'm Charles Melton I'm here at
BuzzFeed and I'm here to play with some
puppies and answer some questions
[Music]
hey I'm good our name you brownie are
you more like Daniel from the Senators
also a star or Reggie from Riverdale I'm
more like Daniel from the Sun is also a
star it's a hopeless romantic but you
know Reggie's got a sensitive side to
him but uh more like Daniel I'd say come
on come on can you share anything from
the Met Gala last night who are you most
excited to see and hang out with
yeah cher performed last night I
literally ate three servings of mashed
potatoes and the next thing I know
shares on stage seeing and dancing and
what she's incredible right
yeah he did good job what's your
favorite behind-the-scenes memory from
filming Riverdale this was from season
two : I we were filming a fight scene in
the Student Lounge we're getting pretty
into it as this fight scene Cole need me
and then we put in the middle of it I
was like oh but we kept on going and
then in the next steak I accidentally
kneed him in the it really testing
around still committed to the scene
buddy what's your go-to karaoke song
easy halo by Beyonce halo by Beyonce
yeah yeah
[Music]
that's saving grace which actor would
you love to have guest star on Riverdale
Andrew Garfield Andrew Garfield I
already loves the show did you always
want to be an actor when you're growing
up or did you think about pursuing
football professionally I always wanted
to be an actor it was started at a young
age I wanted to be in movies growing up
and I did thinking about pursuing the
NFL professionally for 10 years you know
but there's steps there's this thing
that they say that a hard work beats
talent when talent doesn't work hard so
everything you know you know with when
it came to sports and everything that I
had to you know work in the offseason
rank is awesome
you know good plays are meaning the
offseason right yeah yeah they are yeah
they are and you can apply that to life
right yes you can
yeah okay what was your favorite TV show
growing up and what are you binge
watching now I can binge watch shows and
one day I binge watch five seasons of
Game of Thrones in ten days my favorite
TV show growing up Stargate my dad's a
huge Stargate fan and we wanted to start
yet growing up and I love spongebob
spongebob was great yeah good time yeah
yeah
yeah okay did you read this sentence
also to start before filming the movie
yes I did I bought the book ten months
before I got the script I read it in two
days and fell in love with the character
and the story because there's so many
timely things and you know in the film
and in the book that I feel like a lot
of people can connect to especially to
the aspirational love story of the
universal theme of love right we all
love each other right come here come
here we all love each other whoa
it's all love come here how does it feel
to help bring Asian American
representation to TV and movie what
challenges do you face I'm really proud
to be Asian American and to represent
the community in TV and film by group a
military kid a mother screen my father's
American as far as challenges I feel
like you can overcome challenges so as
long as you you know believe hey that's
my question buddy hey what's the role
that you auditioned for that you didn't
get but really wanted there's so many
there's so many roles that I wanted that
I didn't get but that's you know that's
part of this business
have tough skin when I auditioned for
Riverdale I went in four times in a span
of a month okay what's your favorite
animal
right now dogs I love dogs I have a dog
a childhood dogs things Diamond Jack
he's 16 years old I've said goodbye to
all quite a few times
but he's still going he's still truckin
see I was the number one dog walker in
Los Angeles I tell everybody I was the
number one dog walker but I truly was I
was walking on this app called wag and I
walked over 300 dogs in two months
crazy right you'd write reviews on these
dogs there's a poop button @p button you
write reviews on them
I still get notifications on my phone
with dog with West like hey so-and-so
would like for you to walk the dog yeah
cuz I cuz I'm a good dog alright oh
what's your go-to Starbucks order
americano or iced americano
you earned it because your brothers and
sisters over here just chillin what's
your fun background right now it's just
a black background cuz all my abs can
you know it gets good you used to be my
mom this beautiful photo of my mom
looking at the window in Kansas but
anymore this is the last one because all
these cuties and all the other questions
hey that's my plan hey oh he's eating a
question right now when you were a kid
who was your role model easy it just
depended on the day but it was either my
mom or my dad thanks BuzzFeed these dogs
are up for adoption that rescue City so
look at them
they're so cute okay can you zoom in the
hand right there just sleeping so cute
rescue city guys thank you for having me
I'm Charles Melton and the Sun is also
started comes out May 17th so be sure to
see it and bye guys
[Music]